we did put a call out to our YouTube
community and we asked for bad pitches
and we had a tremendous uh response
here's just a few of our favorites there
were so many great ones to choose from
uh this one the username is the Soylent
company
um
it's not real that's a anyway a brand um
so here's the pitch so there's a guy who
can't open this jar of pickles so he
runs around Los Angeles trying to find
ways to open uh the jar of pickles he
finds himself in weird situations as
well as in more and more trouble in the
end he finds a girl that has been trying
to open a jar of jelly
they managed to open the jars in the end
and then they sit down and they watch
Shrek together the end
may I
oh man please please I'll just tell you
everything that I've learned and I've
been taught
it's not a story
it's not a story uh and a pitch has to
give you a sense of story storytelling
is everything that's the biggest thing
in this book I think and and first of
all it's silly it's an incident it's a
little sketch of people I don't have any
details I don't know I guess it's funny
in a kind of great school I mean I'm
sorry I apologize and then the the other
thing is that it makes the mistake of
a lot of writers I've made it to is the
is the the Greek the the bringing
something in at the last moment you know
um out of nowhere the girl appears and
she's got a jar of jelly or whatever
also I have to say that I think most
people would stop listening after a guy
has a jar of pickles
because you haven't told me anything
about the person you you haven't started
with the character and what his problem
is he's got a jar of pickles he can't
open I have that problem it's 15 16
times a day
not pickles other things everything
anyway that's why I think that doesn't
work Peter may have some other thoughts
about that or he can go on to the next
one okay
well let me just there's no conflict
there's no conflict okay but there's a
conflict in that he can't
get a result that he wants which is to
open this jar but let's say a conflict
is different than a problem
yeah it's not going to be something
that's going to carry you
okay okay
and and again if the conflict has no
consequence and no import
foreign
you got nothing okay
uh here's another uh quote unquote bad
pitch from um viewer Judah harad
and Judah writes an ex Vietnam veteran
who is also an ex- Samurai who then
became a police officer who then gained
super powers from a fly who then became
a samurai fly and can kill people with
one type of a finger the villain is a
robber who gets put out within the first
15 minutes because of the one tap
well I've got thoughts about it but you
go ahead go ahead okay I need you to
reread it to me sure okay here we go so
and X Fiat excuse me an X Vietnam
veteran who is also an ex- Samurai who
then became a police officer who then
gained superpowers from a fly who then
became a samurai fly and can kill people
with one top of a finger the villain is
a robber who gets put out within the
first 15 minutes because of the one tap
okay let's take the first half first you
just told me everything
uh it's too much I think he's a Vietnam
veteran and then I'm getting all these
things you're telling me you're loading
it up up front and and I my head is
spinning I think it's funny I think the
funny part of it is the being in you
know infected by the fly and getting the
getting the superpowers
I also don't think you should ever call
someone a villain in a pitch because it
takes their Humanity out
um villains are usually one-dimensional
in like you know they used to be they're
not anymore I I just give you die hard
as the perfect example he's more
interesting than the Bruce Willis
character the the late great Alan
Rickman so uh that's my thing it again
it's you're you're rushing the story and
you're putting too much on the main
character on the protagonist it's very
hard to buy all of those things so pick
one
a guy gets
superpowered from a fly I want to know
more about that I don't know Peter you
have something to add to that
well I mean for openers we go back to
the conflict issue that
and there's a bad guy and he kills him
one shot
why did he need killing why was he a bad
guy why do we care I'm telling too much
how do we how do we worry about a guy
who has all these superpowers there's
nothing in there to really like or
admire or be concerned about so there's
no character that you care about you
know what happens to him you don't care
what happens to your protagonist you
have no story right and he's obviously
Invincible with all of these Powers so
you have somebody that you might as well
have hey if it's a guy that got a big
Steamroller and there's a little guy
that he's mad at so he runs him over
yeah I mean and if he makes him a
samurai Steamroller you know the reason
sorry go ahead no it's it's silly and
but you've front loaded him with too
many characteristics right and if
there's a good story about how he got
all of these things maybe that would
draw you in but there's no hint that
you're going to hear that story
and then you've got a bad guy who you
don't care about but he dies anyway
one of the things that I've I've been
really pleased about with the
undergraduate it's an LMU and I hope
that other film schools are doing more
of this is we have a class now finally
for the last seven years for freshmen it
is about storytelling it's not primarily
about storytelling for film or
television it's about storytelling
because all storytelling is the same and
it has the same rules same as business
telling a story in business
and I think that you by the time they
become seniors they know the basics and
they they wouldn't make that mistake I
think these people are trying to write
bad pictures which is they're probably
really good writers so I just want to
get that in guys
we see through you you mentioned Forrest
Gump in the book and when when it was
Pitch you said it took 10 years or so
eight or ten yes it was really the hero
of that was the producer Wendy fireman
who just would and there was a novel so
it wasn't start you know it had Source
material and they I know we my wife and
I are very close friends with someone
who got a million dollars to
to write a draft of it uh the guy that
wrote On Golden Pond was and has an
Academy Award Ernest Thompson also wrote
a draft I don't think a word of their
drafts were used but they did get a
million dollars each so it was very very
difficult to get that done I tell you
then you look back on it you say and
everybody's copied that that structure
you know that goes backward and forward
in time and uses the bench as to hold
the structure in place so it's an
episodic movie so I'm sorry but what was
your question well when it was pitched
were there holes that people found in it
what was it was the story too hard well
why should we care about this guy well
I'm wondering I mean I've read a little
bit about it
um and I think I think it was just they
they were worried that it was too
episodic and that he wasn't active
enough that it was the other characters
but when you really look at the movie
and I've studied the movie I loved the
movie
um it's he changes lives his own life
also changes a little but it's the other
people he affects and if he were not
there they wouldn't change I mean it is
it's unusual it was a hard sell as we
know but I can think of 10 or 20 movies
that had this that are simpler in
structure and have the same problem
getting done you know nobody knows I
mean it's the William Goldman thing that
Peter loves that nobody knows anything
right so you know and this is again why
I think TV is going to outshine movies
is it already is is they take more risks
for example I don't know if you've seen
it it's on Apple TV it's over now they
did Four Seasons it's it's about Emily
Dickinson
but the way they did it the pitch was
it's Emily Dickinson set at the time of
Emily Dickinson but we're going to
put them we're going to have them speak
in contemporary dialogues as if we're
now and it's brilliant
and and and and so like you know the
sisters they'll all be sitting around
and they'll get some bad news and one of
them well that really sucks and you
would think that wouldn't work but it's
so well written and I think that's where
chances are being taken you know
how many movies that have come out you
can't include Coda which won the Academy
Award because that was financed by Apple
TV
so how many movies have we got that are
real Risk Takers now big movies I mean
big big film companies and that goes
back to why is it so hard to pitch in
Hollywood right that's the r word I we
always tell us yeah
sorry go ahead
I just think that in I we steer our kids
toward careers in television and this
year
the seniors who wanted to go and that
was 80 percent they're all either about
to get their entry-level jobs or in
entry-level jobs
because that's where the work is
television and its many forms film is
always going to be there but how many
Maverick movies are there going to be
you know with Tom Cruise is going to say
I'll do this that movie only gets made
because Tom Cruise wants to be in it
cyan guard is the is the username
forgive me if I'm mispronouncing it in
this movie we start with the last few
seconds of the movie with a man and a
woman standing atop Rubble looking out
over the ocean Horizon next scene is 30
years earlier a similar scene followed
by 50 years earlier we keep doing this
for the next two hours traveling
backwards thousands of years without
ever drawing any connections between
scenes okay this one's on you
enjoy yourself
now again this is an intentional of
course yeah that's what makes them fun
I guess we would have to help it's all
the same things we've said so far sure
no story no conflict we have no
character no details get attached to
there's there's no plot there's no
you've got to give me in the hook
a sense of why they're standing on that
Rubble why are they there and why should
I care I don't know if you find this
interesting
um
okay
Jeffrey gets to teach screenwriting so
he's working with students who want to
learn screenwriting they're very
sophisticated I get a lot of business
folks that I'm trying to teach these
very basic concepts too
so I I do a little exercise with them
where I start out saying well let me let
me tell you something
woman sits down at a computer she writes
something out in a word processor a hits
print and gets your document
is that a story
and they kind of look at me quizzically
and say sounds more like an incident to
me than a story
so what would make it more story like
well we don't have any conflict at all
so how about if she goes to the printer
and gets an error message it doesn't do
it
so now we have a little more something
happening but why do we care
who's she why do we care if she gets her
document printed
well how about we'll give her a name
well we'll call her Anna
she just graduated from college and this
is her first job
and she's the first
first person in her family to ever go to
college
this is her first day on the job
and she's the only Latino working there
and she can't get her document printed
so all of a sudden now we start to feel
a little bit for her because we're
feeling like first person in a family
first person with the job so we sort of
like her a little bit and she's in
trouble
say now how can we beef this up a little
bit well how about if we find out that
John in the I.T department is really
pissed that she got the job because he
wanted his friend to get it but they
gave it to a Latina
so she didn't get it because she was
good she got it because she was female
and Latin
so he
mucked up the printer
so now we have a little more of a
conflict we've got somebody we can
dislike and so we keep adding these
elements and just a long story short
we find out we we jack up the conflict a
little the boss needs the document he's
going on a business trip at five o'clock
he's leaving the office
it's just about five o'clock the printer
ain't working and then she says I'll
email it to him
story's over oh okay but but in each
element we're saying the more now if we
wanted to make this a better story how
could we care more about her
how can we make John a bigger jerk
right so all the way along we're looking
at what are the elements that make a
story that's very helpful I bet for
business people because it's simple and
it's clear Essences and what we're doing
is we're making it additive we're at
each step we're saying just this little
tweak notice how it changes oh we went
from I don't care at all to I kind of
care
right oh I know I care more yeah a poor
girl that's son of a [ __ ] you know in
most
just I'm so just one last thing sure but
I find it's really it's really helpful
to do it socratically so in each case I
don't say let's add this it's what would
make it more exactly and then we we play
around with answers too but you're also
by doing it socratically you are
you are
aping the way it's done in the real
world we don't just sit there and talk
of people I'll say the first just to
give another example of the simpler and
not as maybe not as powerful as what
Peter just did but the first thing I
just taught about writing when was a kid
is what's the difference between
the queen died the king died and the
queen died the king died of grief
and right away
you know
um you have the makings of a story when
you say grief
um
I'm not I'm just saying that sometimes I
mean the other thing that's really
powerful about Peter's example is it's
simple it's straightforward and it's it
gets specific
and I think
details really matter in storytelling
and I think a lot of people rush I've
done it I know so I've made the mistake
you really want to tell that story so
either you tell too much or you tell too
little
did you want to give us another one this
is fun I like how you like this which is
a new game but just the one thing is by
by doing it socratically they're
learning to ask those questions and and
by the way if they go into a writer's
room or they go into uh
um our one person we interviewed David
Alper who
that PepsiCo they taught and one of the
things he was put in charge of was he
tells that great story about the Apple
watch and the but is to Mentor younger
people because they wanted to create the
next generation of leaders and they said
in a room you don't get to listen you
have and this is the same in Hollywood
those two things are identical if you
sit silently in a writer's room goodbye
goodbye you're being paid a lot of money
to be here to offer your